He's the kind of person we should listen to.
There's a reason he Rose in such a popularity because people are resonating with
his ideas. Now, even if I don't, I can at least recognize, well,
here's a voice maybe I should pay attention to.
I might learn something from him.
That line in the sand that we both want drawn.
It seems impossible for liberals to do at a systemic level,
meaning the individuals we've talked about this many times that I believe
individuals can do it,
but it seems like systems based on that seem unable to, uh,
unable to stand up to it.
So I thought this will be a great segue to talk about the,
the differences that you have with Jordan Peterson.
I thought I have to read actually the blurb that Jordan wrote on the back of the
book, because I've literally never seen, uh,
a statement like this written on the back of someone's book before,
and that'll be a good launch point for us. So Jordan wrote,
this is a rather difficult book for me to blurb,
given that an entire chapter is devoted to criticizing my claims
about pragmatic truth vis-a-vis scientific truth. However,
Dr. Michael Shermer is a very clear thinker and the kind of skeptic that is
always necessary to ensure that the pub that public thought scientific and
otherwise maintains a certain clarity.
He's a passionate advocate of free speech for this and many other reasons to the
point of entitling his new book, giving the devil his due,
which is devoted to many worthwhile topics, but to free speech above all,
despite our disagreements, this is a necessary book for our times,
read it and thank God and the powers that be that you have the right to do so.
So I think it's sort of perfect because it's a summation of what we all know
about Jordan. Um, but the fact that you asked him to do it,
despite having a chapter in here, which grapples with all of his ideas. Um,
and I do think this is sort of linked to the question that I'm asking you about
liberalism.
So can you sort of unpack what your similarities and differences are with
Jordan?
Yeah, I think, uh, you know,
when I first saw Jordan on your show and Joe show and sorry, who is this guy?
You know, like everybody else, like who is this guy? Uh, to me,
I was dying to know what it is. He thought about things.
Although at the same time I could see mostly liberals again,
trying to shut him down or call him Hitler, whatever.
I mean a bigot and a misogynist and whatnot. And then when I met him,
I thought this guy is a super good guy. I mean, I,
I could see why I don't agree with him on this and that, but you know,
he's the kind of person we should listen to.
There's a reason he Rose in such a popularity because people are resonating with
his ideas. Now, even if I don't, I can at least recognize, well,
here's a voice maybe I should pay attention to.
I might learn something from him. And, uh,
so the two chapters at the end of the book,
that chapter on Jordan and the chapter on Graham Hancock,
who I was on Joe Rogan's podcast with, and then I got to know, it's like, okay,
this guy is an alternative archeologist.
He has some ideas that most archeologists think are crazy, are way out there,
uh, not substantiated. And, uh, and yet he makes a pretty good arguments.
He's a great writer. And, you know, from there,
I think this is the kind of people we got to give a voice to and, and,
and acknowledge that, you know,
maybe we don't have time to listen to every single person out there, but,
you know,
pick and choose the ones that are very popular because they must be saying
something that resonates with people. Now Jordan's theory of truth. You know,
it's sort of a blend of Charles Darwin and William James sort of a pragmatic
evolutionary pragmatism. And I don't want to misquote his, his theory.
You can listen to four hours of him and Sam kind of hashing this out.
It goes on for that long and, and his books, uh, of deconstruct all that.
But near, as I could tell, it would be something like, um, you know, if, if,
if you believe it's true and it, and it works pragmatically speaking, then,
then you can use the word truth to it. And I think it comes down to,
what do you mean by that? Like,
so was Jesus resurrected from the dead now? You know,
most Christians today say yes, absolutely. You know,
someone named Jesus existed,
he was crucified and he Rose from the dead and, you know,
a hundred billion people have lived and died before the seven and a half billion
people alive. Now not one of them is back from the dead except this one, maybe.
Okay. So that's the, that's the argument now from a skeptic's perspective,
I would say, well, that is an extraordinary claim.
How extraordinary a hundred billion to one extraordinary, right.
Is the evidence for it corresponding or in proportion to that hundred
billion to one odds. And, and the answer is no. And so I write about that, but,
but to Jordan,
I think he would say whether it happened or not is irrelevant,
it's mythically true or psychologically true.
That is you have a cross to bear.
You might say a burden to carry of the suffering of
yourself and your family and friends or humanity or whatever forgiveness,
you know,
starting over this kind of resurrection of your own life to
rebuild. It's like the no-action flood story.
It's a story of sort of destruction and redemption.
It's a kind of a born again story.
So I think what Jordan is arguing is that has mythic power.
That is a kind of truth. Uh.
But that's sort of like an eternal,
an eternal truth underneath the empirical truth, something like that.
Right, right. That's right.
So it could be that people like me and Jordan or someone like maybe Richard
Dawkins in Jordan or whoever that's kind of an empiricist,
they're just talking to two different levels. I think, uh, you know,
Jordan's not always super clear about this,
so you have to kind of read what he said here or there or whatever,
but I think that's, what's going on. And so to the extent that, uh, you know,
he likes to quote young and, and Freud and Nietzsche and, and,
and Tolstoy and so on. And it's like Shakespeare Jane Austin.
The reason this is great literature is because it's tapping about the
reality of human nature, human relationships, societies, conflict,
power struggles, sex, and gossip, and, you know,
conflict and violence war.
Those are all realities that everybody knows.
And these great novelists can tap into that.
There's a whole study now of evolutionary literary sort of evolutionary
psychology of literature, where they kind of, they,
they do a content analysis of great works to see which kind of themes come up
over and over and over. And they're the deepest themes that we all care about.
Again, that the sort of hierarchy, social status, power,
deception, honesty, love, sex, all that.
And so there,
I think what Jordan is arguing that I would agree with that there are truths
there now that's a good, but that's different than an empirical truth. Like,
so the analogy I make is like,
people will often send me as the editor of skeptic magazine articles explaining
what really happened with the flood. You know, you know,
meteor Stryker was a volcano eruption, not the flood,
like the parting of the red sea se, but the flood also,
or the Jew Jesus was on the cross.
And then somebody gave him this chemical through the rag and that put him into a
coma and then they put him in the tomb and then he woke up and then his
disciples wisdom off to France. Yeah.
And he married Mary Magdalene and they had kids and, and, and,
and the bloodline is still around. This was of course Dan Brown's novel.
That was a real book actually before Dan Brown was a book called Holy blood,
Holy grail. And they actually,
those guys sued Dan Brown for stealing their idea. He's like,
it's a novel dudes. Is that right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
He sold so many books, man. If, if, if you don't sell any books,
no one's going to Sue you because there's no money. Right. So it was,
it was kind of like there, you saw the difference, you know, Dan,
Dan Brown's novel resonated. Cause it's, it's just a story.
He's not claiming it's empirically true. But these guys, the Holy blood,
Holy grail authors, um, that, you know, they were saying, no, no, this,
this really happened. Okay.
So those are two different ways of saying really happened or truth, you know?
So do you think it's possible that we need both of those?
I think maybe that's the position that I've come around to,
that we need empirical truths. We need scientific truths. Absolutely.
But when you talk about that, that other layer that Jordan's talking about,
the sort of time-tested things about purpose and happiness and,
and individualism and the drive to,
to accomplish what humans are sort of here to do that for me, I've come to,
and this is, this is one of the spots. And when I was just on your show,
you were, you were asking about, because I write about this in my book,
I've come to the place where for a society to organize itself properly,
it does need some other ethos beneath it. And what I,
I think is something like when you talk about Shakespeare and all the authors
that write about these themes, too, that in and of themselves, those stories,
aren't enough to organize a society around. Not that again,
that individuals can't do it,
but for actually for a to function properly.
Do you think there's some truth to that?
Yeah, I do. For sure. I mean, there's a reason why, uh, drama,
films and television sells or has a much bigger
viewerships than documentary films. I mean, it's very rare.
Any documentary film gets, you know, millions of views. There's a few,
but not many. And, and, and the reason is,
is because we're storytelling animals and we're moved emotionally, deeply,
psychologically moved by a story, you know, about some person now, like when,
uh, uh, Spielberg made Schindler's list. Um, you know,
it's not a story of the Holocaust because that's too big a subject. I mean,
you'd have, you could have like a Ken burns 13 part series on the Holocaust.
People have done this because there's so many stories instead,
he just took one little story. Okay. This guy, Oscar Schindler,
who was this guy, and, you know,
Conneely wrote that novel about him sort of a semi true novel.
Okay. So if you really look at it, it's not that interesting, the story,
but when you bring it on the big screen and then you build in the Holocaust
around that story, but it's the narrative thread that goes throughout.
So all filmmakers know this. Most of us non-fiction writers.
We don't understand, you got to have a narrative story. You know,
you got to have an arc to it, right. Poles, right. Roles,
readers along good writers, do that. Uh, and filmic good filmmakers do that.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about academia,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our academia playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.